one good way to understand slope is to
look at a ski lift you would see
different lines here and all of them are
tilted at various angles just look at
the figure don't think too much
simply look and guess which line has the
greatest slope and which one has the
smallest clearly this slope is the
greatest that's because it's tilted the
most and this one is the smallest as it
has a very tiny tilt a line like this
will have a greater slope if it has a
steep inclination and a line like this
one which has a gradual inclination will
have a smaller slope understanding
slopes is easy and there is also a way
in which a slope can be measured the
slope is simply a ratio it is the ratio
of rise over run what does this ratio
actually mean to understand this let's
draw the coordinate plane it has the Y
and the X axes how do we find the slope
of this line to find the slope we just
have to pick any two points on the line
any two and from the bottom point we
need to reach the top one by rising and
running yes rise and run think of a
little man doing it to reach from the
bottom point to the one on top he rises
and runs does the slope also have a sign
so before understanding how a slope can
be measured let's understand its sign
yes the sign of the slope depends on the
sign of rise and run a good way to
understand that is by knowing that
rising up is always positive and running
to the right is also positive going down
or running left will both be negative
here the rise as well as the run a
positive so the slope will be a ratio of
two positive numbers positive over
positive will give us a positive number
this line we can say has a positive
slope now
look at this line we use the same
procedure we mark two random points on
the line and to go from the bottom point
to the top one we rise and run if we
look at the little man he rises up and
runs to the left rising up is positive
and running to the left is negative so
the slope of this line will be positive
over negative and this ratio will be
negative this line has a negative slope
what about the slope of this line which
is parallel to the x-axis you don't
really need to mark two points to find
its slope it has no tilt it means the
rise will be zero so the slope will
equal zero over run which is zero the
slope of the x-axis is also zero what
will be the slope of this line which is
parallel to the y-axis it's simple you
cannot run left or right after marking
two points the run is zero so the slope
will be rise over zero and anything over
zero is undefined the slope of a line
parallel to the y-axis is undefined or
as some say is infinite now if we have
understood the concept of signs finding
the slope is very easy so let's move on
to finding the slope of a line how do we
find the slope of this line we have been
given the coordinates of two points on
the line one is 2 comma 3 and the other
is minus 2 comma -3 to find the slope we
just need to find the ratio of rise over
run okay let's shift the camera to the
right the slope is rise over run how do
we find the rise simple we just find
this length to find this length we need
the coordinates of this point as it
meets the x axis at minus 2 and the y
axis at 3 its coordinates will be minus
2 comma 3
rice will be the difference in the
y-coordinates 3 - -3 the run will be
this length which is the difference in
the x-coordinates of these two points
- - minus 2 the slope is 6 over 4 which
is 3 over 2
the rise as well as the run are positive
up and right if the two points are X
comma Y and x1 comma y1 then the formula
of the slope is y minus y1 over X minus
x1 3 minus minus 3 is actually Y minus
y1 and 2 minus minus 2 is X minus x1
that's how we calculate the slope of a
line in the next few sessions we will
see how the slope and the equation of
the line are related